[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Thank
you so much for coming.
And I'm not going to bore
you to death, I hope.
And I hope some
of you are eating,
because I can smell delicious
smells coming up here.
So when I decided to do "New
York in a Dozen Dishes,"
the whole idea was to
characterize the city
as it is right now,
to give a little kind
of thumbnail portrait
based on 12 dishes.
Actually, I cheated, and
there's 13, one of which
is the black and white cookie.
Has anyone had a black
and white cookie ever?
Well, there's a weird story
behind black and white cookies.
So when you can find
it, if you buy the book,
or if you just go
into the bookstore
and-- what's a bookstore?
If you can go into the bookstore
and then read the last chapter,
you'll find out
that it's related
to Henry Hudson and his
ship called The Half Moon.
Anyway, so when I decided
to pick out the dishes
that I was going to
have for the 12 dishes,
the first thing
I did was decided
that it couldn't just all be
dishes that were really famous
and everybody knew.
I could write about pizza.
I could write about
fried chicken.
I could write about hamburgers.
And I did write
about two of those.
But I didn't want it to be
all dishes that everybody
knew about it and had
written like a zillion times
about already.
I didn't want to be just
like a synopsis of what
had gone before.
So I picked out some dishes that
were kind of not as well known.
Dishes that people
seemed to be enjoying,
but were much harder to find.
As a matter of fact, you might
even call them fringe dishes.
Anybody recognize this?
You can get this in several
New York restaurants
that I know about.
AUDIENCE: Guinea pig.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Ever see-- oh!
Guinea pig.
Who said that?
Was that you, Kelly?
She probably already knew.
And who knows what a Guinea pig
is, besides the furry pets shop
friend?
Yes.
It's a furry rodent.
And with the rodent,
you got it right.
I mean, it's a close cousin of
the thing that scampers away
from the garbage cans
when you go look out
behind the restaurant.
And as a matter of
fact, when you see it,
the thing that it's
missing here is the fur.
When you see it in the
pet shop, it's gigantic.
When you see it on a bed of--
does anyone know what that
is there that it's sitting on?
It's corn.
It's hominy corn.
It's like what they make
hominy grits out of.
It's called mote in the
South American parlance.
And look at those
cute little teeth.
Isn't that cool?
So anyway, I decided
that I was going
to write about cuy, which
is what they call it,
because cuy was
beginning to appear
in places like Sunset Park
with Ecuadorian immigrants.
Now in Ecuador and in
the chapter about cuy,
I eventually go to Ecuador to
check out the underpinnings.
In Ecuador, every
housewife keeps cuy.
And she keeps them
in her garden.
And the cuy is there
mainly so that the dad
can get an aphrodisiac,
which is why the head is
the most important part.
At any rate-- oh, I
just love these slides.
[LAUGHTER]
At any rate, the women that live
in the alta plano in Ecuador,
they keep these cuy, they
keep them in the garden,
and they add a little row
of bricks around the garden.
Does anyone know what
the bricks are for?
Well, it's to keep
the cuy from escaping.
Because the cuy,
they want to escape.
They're just like
condemned prisoners.
But they can't climb
over a single brick.
They are incredibly
uncoordinated
and incredibly unathletic.
Like me, and a lot of people.
If there was a
wall of bricks, I'm
not quite sure I could
climb over it either.
And here's someone
enjoying the cuy.
I took a couple of
friends with me.
Oh, this is nice.
There's a clock now.
You will pick out the person
in the audience probably
who's eating the cuy there
and kind of holding it up.
So anyway, cuy are rodents,
and they're not strictly legal
here in the United States.
So supposedly I
had to figure out
whether the cuy were coming
in suitcases with immigrants,
or whether people were actually
ranching the cuy somewhere
up in Westchester, like
sitting on little Shetland
ponies and kind of
like herding the cuy.
Can you imagine?
There must be a whole
set of songs and stuff
that you sing while
you're herding cuy.
I'm not sure.
And why not just get
a rat and eat it?
It's not really that different.
And anyway, cuy is one
of those fringe dishes
which is popular among people
from Brazil, from Peru.
And for the longest time,
you couldn't find it.
And now it's beginning
to appear again.
But you know, cuy is
one of those dishes
that doesn't travel well.
Unless you're standing at two
miles up with the sun directly
overhead and the wind
from down below kind of,
and feeling kind of sick
from altitude sickness,
the cuy is just
not quite the same.
So another thing that has been
appearing-- as you can see,
that's for two cuy.
So it's rather expensive.
Well, yeah, the cuy they're
not-- well, they could be rats,
but they're not.
And they're expensive.
So this is another
thing that discourages
Ecuadorian immigrants from
eating them in restaurants,
and why they're
still kind of rare.
But if you were to look
for them these days,
I would say go to
Bushwick and walk along
Wyckoff, and kind of look
in the windows of some
of the Ecuadorian bodegas.
And you'll see that you
can get the cuys much more
cheaply if you buy them
frozen and cook them at home.
And guess what?
The fur is already gone.
That's the hardest thing.
What do they taste like?
They taste kind of like
a little bit like pig.
The skin is the best part.
The skin is incredibly thin and
crunchy, like a suckling pig.
So hence, perhaps, Guinea pig.
Has anyone here been
to Franklin Barbecue?
Oh my god.
You have?
How long did you
have to wait in line?
AUDIENCE: Hours.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
Franklin Barbecue is now the
best barbecue in the United
States, perhaps in the world.
What city is it in?
AUDIENCE: Austin.
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
Austin, Texas, which
is kind of the center
of great barbecue.
But for decades,
they didn't really
have much good barbecue
in the city limits.
But now all of
these new barbecue
revivalists like Aaron Franklin
have started making it.
I'm going to go through
these slides quickly,
because they're just
here for atmosphere.
But any engineers here?
There must be plenty
of engineers here.
This is a secret shot that
I surreptitiously took
of the super secret smoke room.
This is the way
Aaron Franklin smokes
his ribs and his brisket.
And he does it with-- if
you look in the front,
that black square is
the thing that has
the fire box in front of it.
And this is a 19th
century German engineering
miracle that was used in
places like Kreuz Market.
When I first saw
it, it blew my mind.
Because they would have
a little fire in front,
and smoke blowing
through the fire.
And through a series
of underground sluices
to these brick pits
with hinged lids.
So in other words,
they found a way
to have less smoke and less
wood go through more smokers.
And this is exactly
the same thing
that Aaron has ripped
off in his own smoke room
where he has-- does
anyone recognize
what he's used as the smokers?
Something like septic tanks.
But giant propane tanks
is the way that he did it.
And it's really quite brilliant.
And using just one fire at the
end of every series of tanks,
he has a capacity far
in excess of the amount
he would need just to generate
food for the restaurant.
This is a typical
Franklin spread here.
Some of his homemade
sausage, some
of his brisket, smoked
turkey, pulled pork,
and there was something
else in there--
and ribs up in the
upper right hand corner,
with the usual no account sides.
In Texas, you don't go to
barbecue for the sides.
You go there for the meat.
And the meat there
is just mind blowing.
It took me a little
while to figure out
what he was doing that made his
barbecue the best in the world,
other than just using this
19th century German technology
and smoking it a
fuckload of time.
[LAUGHTER]
See?
You say fuck, and
everybody laughs.
Does anyone know what his
super secret trick is?
Anyone bought his
cookbook and have
an idea what his secret
is, his dirty secret?
Some of the people that went
with me to Franklin Barbecue
when we went just a few weeks
ago know what the secret is.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Picks through
the high quality animals.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
He decided for the
first time ever
to use actual prime meat,
to use the kind of meat
that you get when you go
to a fancy steakhouse, that
is characterized by being so
marbled with fat that it just--
because the fat is
what barbecue is about.
So let's see.
And we took a drive in
the Texas hill country
afterwards, completely
blissed out with the meat.
And these are Texas
peaches, which
you can get around
Fredericksburg only
for a couple of
weeks every year.
Just fantastic peaches.
And what am I doing next here?
Anyone recognize where this is?
One of the chapters
of the book is
about how great barbecue came
to New York for the first time.
And this is a line
in front of one
of our most famous barbecues.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Which one?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: No.
Good guess.
You're in the
right neighborhood.
Briskettown, also known
as Delaney Barbecue.
That's right.
And here just like they
have lines at Franklin's, we
have lines here to get--
or used to have lines here.
Now we have so many
barbecues that no one really
has to wait in line anymore.
Well, there are still
lines, actually.
Yes, it's Delaney Barbecue,
also known as Briskettown.
Delaney is a kind of
an interesting guy.
He can't really get the identity
of his restaurant straight.
He calls it something
different all the time.
So there's two of the
names right there.
Is it Briskettown?
Is it Delaney Barbecue?
And let me see.
Here is his brisket,
which I kind of like over
photoshopped it, so you can't
really see it that well.
Here's the ribs.
Does anyone here like barbecue?
[LAUGHTER]
Good, good, good.
I was worried that
everyone was a vegetarian.
They were going, oh,
that is disgusting.
That is worse than
the Guinea pig.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
These are the ribs of pigs.
And this is one of the
weirdest fetishes of barbecue.
What is that stack
of stuff in the back?
White bread from
the supermarket.
Who has ever eaten a
piece of white bread
from the super market in years?
To begin with, nobody
eats bread at all.
But that's one of
the accoutrement, one
of the fetishes
of great barbecue,
is that you're always
have to eat it with bread.
Or at least my daughter claims
that that's my invention,
but it's not true.
Everyone who's over
50 eats barbecue
by wrapping it in a
piece of white bread
and just tucking a pickle and
some jalapeno peppers in there.
Let me try to go-- this is
another barbecue spread.
Does anyone know,
just by the way
it looks, where it comes from?
I'm testing your
barbecue knowledge
of the great city of New York.
This is one of the
greatest places
to eat barbecue
in the world now.
Not quite as good as Texas, but
you don't have to drive as far.
I'll keep going.
Tell me when you
figure out what it is.
Oh.
And this, if you're
a barbecue nut,
you know that this is one of
the weirdest barbecue offerings.
Its prime rib done barbecue
style, but left rare.
So in other words, it's not
really smoked that long.
But it still tastes
really smokey.
And this-- anybody
know what this is?
Beef rib.
Yes.
Beef rib-- a friend of
mine, Daniel Vaughn, who's
the barbecue editor
of Texas Monthly,
he dug back into
barbecue history
and discovered that
brisket was not
like the most important
barbecue item until the 1950s,
that before that basically
the barbecuers would just
barbecue whatever they had
on hand that nobody wanted.
And beef rib is rapidly becoming
the most popular barbecued item
in a lot of Texas and in a
lot of New York barbecues.
This is a beef rib.
As you can see, it gets
really, really intense looking.
Very, very fatty.
Absolutely delicious.
Don't you dare put any
barbecue sauce on it.
There's two kinds of
people that eat barbecue.
There's people that eat
barbecue for the barbecue,
and there's people that
eat it for the sauce.
So if you eat it for
the sauce, don't even
bother getting barbecue.
Just throw something in the
oven and pour barbecue sauce
all over.
I hope I'm not stepping
on anyone's toes there.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, that last few pictures
was from our own Hill Country.
And there are two
Hill Countries.
One of them is in
Downtown Brooklyn.
And both of them are
absolutely fantastic.
The difference is that the
one in Downtown Brooklyn
serves my favorite, which is
hot links, which is something
that I ate when I was
going to high school
in Dallas, Texas,
one of the worst
cities in the
history of the world.
[LAUGHTER]
They killed Kennedy, after all.
This right here is
Hometown Barbecue,
which is in Red Hook Brooklyn.
A really wonderful
barbecue on its own.
There's their brisket
sandwich turned
into New York barbecue
with that onion role, which
is a staple of Jewish delis.
So we have a lot of
fusion going on here.
They even try to
barbecue pastrami.
Here's showing that
they do have lines, too,
here, just like they do
at Franklin's in Texas,
at Hometown.
My advice is to get there
at five minutes before noon
when it opens on Sunday.
Here is some of Bill
Durney's turkey.
Now, I normally
think that turkey
is the worst thing to barbecue.
It's just like so
boring and so dry,
but barbecue guys
have found a way--
I don't know whether
they're shoving balls
of fat down the turkeys
neck or something,
but they found a way
to make turkey fatty.
And that's the
rib, his rib there.
You can see it's blackened
beyond recognition.
Mighty Quinn's at the
Brookdale location.
Another great barbecue place.
And here we are back
into the seafood.
Another chapter is about clams.
So here's some
delicious raw clams.
Does anyone here like raw clams?
Yeah, raw clams are kind
of an acquired taste.
Because raw clams are
kind of like a little bit
skanky and a little bit bitter.
And they're rubbery, like
chewing on rubber bands.
And yet, it's something
that is native New York
seafood since the first
Canarsie Indians put up
their shacks on
legs by Jamaica Bay
and started eating
shellfish raw.
And here's a typical
plate of raw clams.
This one happens to be
in Highland, New Jersey.
It's not quite in New
York, but near Sandy Hook.
And here's Bears, which is
a famous seafood institution
there.
This is clam chowder.
What kind of clam
chowder is this?
The Manhattan Clam
Chowder, which is bullshit.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, the Manhattan
clam chowder
never came from Manhattan.
Manhattan, being
the dominant island,
demanded it be called
Manhattan clam chowder,
but it should be called
Brooklyn clam chowder.
Because who do
you think, looking
at thee sauce surrounding
the clams and the potatoes,
what group do you think
came up with this?
Italians.
Or as they said in
Minnesota, Italians.
Yes.
The Swedes they came up with--
No, it was the Italians.
This is a very Italian,
extremely Sicilian,
seafood soup.
And it is just delicious.
However, I myself prefer
the white clam chowder.
This is the deck at Bears on
a kind of a nice cloudy day.
And this is some
white clam chowder,
which never photographs
well for some reason.
Oh my god.
These people.
I love the way the colors
are translated here.
Anyone recognize where this is?
AUDIENCE: Grand
Central Westboro?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: That's right,
which is one of the best places
if you go and you sit at
that snaking lunch counter,
it's really very inexpensive.
One of the things that I try to
do is find the cheapest eats,
and that's one of
the cheapest places
to get a bowl of clam chowder.
It's still just a few dollars.
it's up in Grand Central
Station, or Grand Central
Terminal as they now call it.
By the way, the ceiling--
another engineering point
here-- the ceiling is one
of the most famous ceilings
in the world.
It was invented by--
anyone know who invented
it, that kind of ceiling?
AUDIENCE: Guastavino.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Guastavino.
And this is one of the most
famous of his creations.
And how he got those tiles to
stick up there, I don't know.
But some of you probably do.
You can see up there,
the list of oysters
that they have raw
is just astonishing.
And the provenance of
every oyster is well known.
And if you ask, they'll tell
you exactly where it came from,
and when it came from
there, and how fresh it is.
And they're incredibly fresh.
And here's a guy
working some weird ass
contraption that kind of blows
steam up through this soup.
Does anyone know what
the soup is called?
It's not a bisque.
It's the pan oyster roast,
which is completely ridiculous.
Why would you call
it an oyster roast?
They're not roasting it.
They're boiling
it, for God's sake.
And here is the
raw oyster service
with the colors
strangely transformed.
And if you ever miss the
lobster pounds of Maine,
the place to go
is Nick's Lobster,
which is a way at the end
of Flatbush Avenue, almost
in Jamaica Bay.
Anyone been there?
Yes.
It is absolutely astonishing.
This is what it looks
like, which doesn't really
look like New York.
Houses on stilts.
We're looking at
part of Marine Park
there, which of course
flooded completely
during Hurricane Sandy.
But this is one
of only two places
I know in the city that
has houses on stilts.
Kind of very picturesque.
And here you can pick your own
lobster at Nick's, the same way
you can do in Maine.
And here's the
happy outdoor space.
If you take the Flatbush
bus for about five hours,
you'll end up here.
[LAUGHTER]
And here is their delicious
clam chowder turned
a strange shade of green.
Normally it's white and
pasty, filled with clams.
And of course, here is the
money shot of the lobster,
with a little bit of corn
there, the kind of typical shore
dinner.
And here, stuffed clams.
One of my favorite things.
Once again, an
Italian use of clams.
We have a lot to thank
the Sicilians for.
Here's a bowl.
Anybody know what this is?
Gooey.
This is Ecuadorian.
I don't know why I put
this slide in here.
[LAUGHTER]
Gooey duck?
Great.
Actually, it's gooey foot.
This is cow-foot soup from
an Ecuadorian restaurant.
But gooey duck was
an excellent guess.
And here is a woman
selling tamales
by the side of the street.
I don't know why I
put this in here.
But it just shows New York
is one of the greatest places
to eat in the world.
No.
I'll say it.
The greatest place
to eat in the world.
And you don't have to
spend an arm and a leg.
As a matter of fact,
a stunt I'm going
to be doing for "Eater New
York," the week after next,
we're having cheap eats week.
And they're going to make
all the employees eat
all their meals out for
less than $10 a day.
And I can do it
through women like this
who are selling these humongous
tamales is for $1 apiece.
You can have them
filled with peppers,
or with mole and
chicken, or with pork
and fiery hot green sauce.
So I think that's it.
So thank you so much for
listening to my rant.
[APPLAUSE]
I think Michael is going to come
up here and ask some questions.
Oh.
There you are.
MICHAEL: Maybe for people
who don't know you,
you could explain
the devil mask.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Can anyone tell
me why I'm wearing this mask?
I lost a bet, yes.
Well actually, I found over
the years that wearing the mask
makes me much more persuasive.
You might not listen
to some mousy critic,
but you're going to
listen to the devil.
[LAUGHTER]
So anyway, I'm
wearing it because I'm
an anonymous critic.
And since this is
being videotaped,
I don't want anyone who's a
chef or works in a restaurant
to be able to look at the
video and see what I look like,
and then put a picture of me up
in the-- as if they even would.
But I believe in anonymity,
because to me, the critic
should always be on the
side of the consumer.
In other words, most
critics spend their time
kissing chef ass and
getting free food and stuff.
But my whole idea, since I'm
funded by the great Vox empire,
I can afford to eat
whatever I want,
and I can afford to do
it anonymously and then
report back to my
readers exactly
what the experience would be
like for them, not just for me.
Anyway.
I'm going to sit down.
MICHAEL: One thing I
was curious about--
so it's so much easier now
to find people like the Arepa
Lady, or interesting food
just through message boards,
from Chow Hound, and
there's so much now.
Before the internet, how did you
find some of this really cool,
unusual stuff?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: It was
actually more fun before.
Now it's just work.
You have to comb The Chow Hound
and Yelp and stuff like that.
And it used to be that I had
all these different ways to do.
The most effective way is just
to pick a spot on the subway
map where you've
never been before,
wait a few hours to
get really, really
hungry so you'll eat anything,
and then jump on the subway
and go to that
stop, and just start
walking in concentric circles.
And typically you'll find
like four, or five, or six
different restaurants.
And there's all sorts of
ways to evaluate them.
You really want to go
in there and kind of
like-- the first
thing you do is smell.
If the restaurant smells bad,
get the hell out of there
as fast as possible.
Then look at the
faces of the people,
if there are any
people in there.
And if there are people in
there, and you see them,
are they eating and
enjoying their food?
Or are they kind of
just nibbling and about
to push the food away?
Then look at the menu.
See if there's something
that you want to eat.
See if there's something that
you've never eaten before.
See if there's something that's
interesting or confuses you.
One of the great
things about this age
is you can whip out your phone
and you can Google up anything
that you see on a menu and
you can find out what it is.
It used to be that you would see
things on menus that you would
go, what the hell is that?
And if you didn't
speak the language
of the people inside
the restaurant,
you would just have to
order it and meet your fate.
But now you can look up and say,
oh my god, that's Guinea pig.
Or oh man, I really
want to try that.
So other ways that
I would find things
is that whenever you go into
a bodega from another culture,
you find these shopping
newspapers where everything is
written in Farsi or something.
But you'll find that the ads for
restaurants always the address
is written in English.
So if you have a Persian
newspaper, and you're reading,
and you see four or
five display ads,
they will tell you where
those restaurants are.
And other ways-- you
get tips all the time.
And you should all send
me tips, by the way.
It's robert@eater.com.
I love to have tips--
when you see places that
have just opened, especially.
Like up on 26th Street, there's
a new Georgian restaurant.
And I'm not talking Georgia
USA, but Georgia SSR.
So anyway, does that
answer your question?
MICHAEL: Yeah.
When did you-- you write a lot
in the book about eating brains
and Guinea pig--
when did you realize
you had a taste
for unusual things,
or that you were
interested in that well?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Well,
I grew up in the Midwest
and in Texas, and at the
time when I was a kid,
we didn't really have much
interesting in the way of food.
We ate meatloaf.
We ate instant mashed potatoes.
We ate frozen peas.
We had stuff like that.
And really I think I
ate out in restaurants
maybe five times before
I went away to college
forever at the age of 16.
And once I had
food in New York, I
tasted something a
little bit exotic.
It just blew my mind.
It was like, how can
something be so good?
How can something be spicy?
How can people put so
much garlic in something?
And it's like, whoa!
I love this stuff.
And I've never stopped.
So I eat out as often
as I can, and I've never
lost the feeling that
there's something really
special about this
city food-wise,
and that there's so much
exciting around this.
I calculate there are 50,000
restaurants in the city.
So how many can you
eat at in a lifetime?
Maybe a thousand?
Two thousand?
MICHAEL: Is there something
you just wouldn't eat again,
that just wasn't worth it?
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
There are definitely
things that I've eaten
that I wouldn't eat again.
But the thing that I
consistently don't like to eat
but eat anyway is brains.
The thing about brains is
that brain's look like brains.
It's almost like you're
a cannibal or something.
They're all gray and wrinkled,
and they're pretty much
all cholesterol.
It's all fat, and
there's nothing in there
to vary the train.
It's all grey custard.
Anyone here like brains?
I know people that
really like brains,
but usually they have a kind
of psychotic edge to them.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't like them.
I've had them.
You also wrote-- I think
I've read you writing about I
think it's maybe Nigerian food.
And there's these--
is it lands slugs?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Oh, yeah.
MICHAEL: Or land snails?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Those
are another good example.
MICHAEL: Those
sound sort of vile.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
Well, there's a lot
of cultures where
they don't have a lot of
toothbrushes and toothpaste
and stuff.
Like if you go to
West Africa, everyone
is chewing on these chew sticks.
And the reason that they
chew on the chew sticks
is that that keeps your
keep relatively healthy.
It kind of acts
like a toothbrush.
By the same token,
one of the things
when I bring friends
to African restaurants,
they take one bite of the
meat and they immediately
turn up their noses.
And they say, oh,
this food is no good.
Why do you think they
say the food is no good?
What is it about the
meat that annoys them?
Anyone have a guess?
Pardon?
Well, completely cooked
is only part of it.
But it is part of it.
Not only is it completely
cooked, but it's tough as hell.
Africans love a good chew.
They want to chew their meat.
They want something
in their mouth.
They eat our meat and
they say, man, you guys
are eating marshmallows.
We're sitting there, oh, I
want a filet mignon that's
really tender.
I've started kind of taking
the African view of things.
I like tender meat.
It's fine.
But chewing is like one of
life's greatest pleasures,
let's face it.
You can chew anytime you want if
you have something to chew on.
So Africans prefer
when they make like--
and another thing is that
they don't, because they have
so little of it back home,
they don't prefer one
sort of protein over another.
They're not saying, oh, yeah.
I want some squid.
And I want-- what
they do when they
make what they call a soup,
which is a stew that they eat
with a mash or with
rice, they will
throw in beef, and chicken,
and fish, and shellfish.
They just load it
down with protein.
And the meat will invariably
be extremely chewy.
This question is
going on forever.
But the whole thing about snails
is that they like to chew.
You cannot chew a snail enough.
These snails are the
size of dinner plates
and they live in trees.
And there's a place in
Brooklyn, in east Flatbush,
that has these snails.
And they are so rubbery that
you need a serrated knife
to cut them.
And then when you
chew them, you're
going to end up spitting it
out because you never chew it
enough to actually get it down.
So it's the African equivalent
of a chew stick when
you get one of these snails.
You could chew it forever.
MICHAEL: You have a
great chapter on pizza.
And I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about-- because I've heard
this rumor for years--
about the connection between
the mafia and pizza cheese.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Oh, yes.
I would love to talk about that.
MICHAEL: Because it's like
a rumor I've heard about,
and then you sort of go
into it a little bit,
and I'm wondering if
you could explain a bit.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: It's
one of the only pieces
of actual investigative
reporting that I've ever done.
But if you walk by
John's of Bleaker Street,
which is one of the four
oldest pizza parlors and one
of the places where
pizza was invented
as we know it worldwide.
Not Italy, New York.
What does it say on the awning?
Does anyone know?
It says no slices.
And that's a weird thing
to put on your awning,
because most pizza
parlors serve slices.
So the reason it says no
slices as far as I can tell
is because they didn't want
the mafia to firebomb it.
The fact of the matter
is, in the '30s and '40s,
Al Capone owned a
series of dairy farms
in Fond Du Lac, Wisconsin,
south of Fond Du Lac,
and these made this
mozzarella cheese
that you may associate with
neighborhood pizza parlors.
It's not really
mozzarella as we now it.
We've all become familiar with
the kind of wonderful squishy
homemade mozzarella.
The pizza, the mozzarella that's
on neighborhood pizza parlors,
is kind of more like
provolone or something.
But anyway, this pizza cheese,
which would keep a long time,
was being manufactured in
Fond Du Lac, Wisconsin,
on dairy farms owned by the mob.
And they went around to all
the neighborhood pizza parlors
and said, you better
use this mozzarella
or we're going to blow you up.
And so all of those
neighborhood pizza parlors
use the same kind of cheese.
This is changing
now, by the way.
You can get what's known
as a grandma slice, where
they use real mozzarella.
But in general for decades,
local pizza parlors
used this kind of
horrible cheese.
In the context of
the pizza, it was OK.
But not as good as mozzarella.
And supposedly the old,
old, old fashioned pizza
parlors where the
mobsters hung out
themselves could use the real
cheese as long as they promised
not to be to serve
slices, which was
the characteristic of the local
neighborhood pizza parlors.
So that's the story.
And I believe that those farms
are still operating and still
producing cheese that
the mob sanctions.
And I won't tell you what
the name of the pizza cheese
company is, but you will see,
like especially in Brooklyn
neighborhood pizza
parlors, a little sign
that says we use
this kind of cheese.
And if you look up the
name of that cheese,
you will find that the corporate
offices are 10 miles south
of Fond Du Lac, Wisconsin.
But since this is being taped
and I don't want to be killed,
I'm not going to mention
the name of the--
but I'll tell you secretly
afterwards, if you come up
and ask me.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL: What do you think about
the rise of the dollar slice
joint, which is sort of
new-- past maybe 5, 10 years?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
I'm supposed to not
like the dollar slices,
but I really love them.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, it's pizza reduced to
its most essential elements.
The cheese is no worse
than the mob cheese.
Maybe there's a
little less of it.
But so what?
What I love is that New
York is so adaptable.
As the real estate prices go
sky high and old restaurants
that we love are forced
to move out and shut down,
the fact that you can
still get a cheap meal
in New York, that they
found ways to do it,
is just so wonderful.
And the dollar slice is
one of the things that
keeps food cheap in New York.
And I have my favorite.
Go to Percy's on Bleaker Street.
They have the best dollar slice.
But even that, Two Guys or
Two Brothers or whatever
is pretty damn good.
MICHAEL: Is there a neighborhood
that you think is just really
exciting right now in terms of
interesting ethnic foods that
seems to be booming, or is
there a new immigrant group
that's producing
foods that you feel
like feels fresh and new, that
you haven't had a lot of--
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Oh, for sure.
I just wrote a piece
in "Eater New York"
about the Venezuelans and
their crazy sandwiches.
How do Venezuelans
make a sandwich?
Anybody know?
MICHAEL: It's huge, right?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
It's big, and they
use fried plantain,
so it's like having two
plates on either side
of your sandwich.
So you have to crunch on it.
The reason being
that they really
didn't have flour in Venezuela
for the longest time.
They had plantains.
They had things like that.
They had both sweet
plantains and they had--
and they make sandwiches
out of those called Yo Yos.
And the sandwiches that they
make out of the hard plantains
are actually a
little harder to eat.
But they're really great.
The Mexicans who started
coming here in the early '90s
are just fantastic.
We're getting a chance to eat
real southern Mexican food,
which is so different
than what they have
in California and in Texas.
And I would say, what's
the best neighborhood
if you wanted to go get a taco?
Where would you go?
There are several
right answers here.
MICHAEL: Sunset Park?
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
Sunset Park is good.
I prefer Bushwick.
The stuff that's going
on in Bushwick taco-wise
is just phenomenal.
You could get all of these
un-reconstructed tacos
are just absolutely fantastic.
Anyone have a favorite
taqueria in Bushwick?
My favorite is right on Myrtle.
It's called Taqueria Izucar.
And it's just fantastic.
Their specialty is suadero,
which is a brisket.
But they also have
phenomenal ear tacos,
where they've stewed the
pig ears for probably days.
And it's just
absolutely fantastic.
MICHAEL: I would love to
open it up to questions.
There's a couple
microphones there
if people-- or you can
just stand up and talk.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Oh, nice.
AUDIENCE: People are
very excited about tacos.
But as a vegetarian, I've never
found any that are interesting.
Do you have any recommendations?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: I would
go-- I forget the name of it.
There's a taco factory--
someone will know.
There's a tortilla
factory in Bushwick--
no, Nick's Tamales in
Queens, is in Corona.
Which one?
Los Hermanos.
Thank you so much.
Yes.
Los Hermanos is
this-- there used
to be seven tortilla
factories in Bushwick,
when you could afford to have
a tortilla factory in Bushwick.
And the one, the Los
Hermanos, or The Women, they
decided that they were going
to go hipster and start
serving tacos.
And they have one
of the best-- you
know, it's not bad to be a
vegetarian and eat tacos,
because there's so many good
tacos that are vegetarian.
And they have a couple
of vegetarian models
that are absolutely fantastic.
And it's very easy to find.
It's a few steps from the
Jefferson stop in Bushwick.
Good question.
MICHAEL: Over there.
Little closer.
Just speak up.
AUDIENCE: Speak out loud?
There we go.
Great.
This is a super annoying
question for a food critic,
but if you had to eat
one meal every day
for the rest of your
life, what would it be?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Oh, man.
That is a good one.
Because it changes every day.
[LAUGHTER]
I ate last night in
a restaurant called
Pharaoh in Bushwick that just
has the most amazing pastas.
They have this
vegetarian pasta that
is gnudi-- does anyone
know what gnudi are?
Gnudi are little Italian
dumplings made with ricotta.
And it had these green
chick peas with it.
And if I had something to pick
right now to eat every day,
it would be that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Thanks
for the question.
MICHAEL: Over there
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I saw that you've
recently done--
I think it was your
piece on "Eater"
about cuisine in New
England, most Connecticut--
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
Oh, Connecticut.
Yeah.
That was fun.
AUDIENCE: And my wife and
I are taking a trip up
to Maine in a few days and
we're going to be driving there,
and I'm curious.
If you had one spot
in Connecticut,
or that part of the
world that you'd
stop for seafood or something
like that, what would it be.
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
That's a good question.
If you look at
the piece, there's
one place that had hamburgers
as well as clam chowder.
And I'll recall the name
afterwards and tell you
what it is.
Yeah, yeah.
And that place is
absolutely fantastic.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
Pizza New Haven is good
MICHAEL: We can
go over here now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is there a particular
cuisine or ethnic food
that you feel like
is under represented
or misrepresented in New York?
And if so, what do
you think it is?
I would just be curious.
I'm probably not as
adventurous as you.
And if so, is there a reason
you think that is the case?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: We
have a lot of cuisines
that we're missing
completely here.
There's historical
reasons for that,
but I would say Laotian and
Cambodian are two cuisines that
are very interesting that are
completely under represented
here.
We have one upscale
Laotian restaurant
that really doesn't cover
the territory very well.
You kind of have to go Nice,
France, or someplace like that.
Or to Laos, of course.
[LAUGHTER]
But that and Cambodian I
would say are examples of two
that we don't have.
We're missing certain cuisines.
Pardon?
Those are totally fake.
They invented those.
They're basically
Vietnamese bon me.
Maybe they serve
them in Cambodia,
but that does not
cover the range.
The best place actually
to get Cambodian cuisine
is in a Vietnamese restaurant.
And the reason is that most
of the Vietnamese people who
lived in the Mekong Delta
southwest of Ho Chi Minh City
are actually from Cambodia, or
have connections with Cambodia.
So many of the
Vietnamese restaurants
have at least a hint
of Cambodian cuisine.
AUDIENCE: Thanks you.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Sure.
MICHAEL: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
There's a place in
Barcelona in Spain
where it's essentially
just one guy.
He runs the whole thing.
He cooks.
He serves people.
He decides what's on the menu.
There is no menu.
Whatever he's cooking.
Super simple food,
but it's amazing,
and it has a lot of personality.
I'm guessing New York, because
it has different legal issues,
and so on, is not the best
place for places like that.
But do you know single
person run places
that have their own flavor?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Who's
that crazy guy on Steinway
that-- yeah, the Egyptian guy.
AUDIENCE: I forget the
name of his restaurant.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
I do, too.
But there are places like that.
Not too many of them.
You're right.
But it's more like--
the guy in Barcelona,
does he not have any
customers or something?
AUDIENCE: No.
He has people that come
there every single day,
and he's been in that
place for 42 years.
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
Because it's very hard
to run a restaurant
for one person.
I've been in restaurants
where one person was
running around being the
waiter, the greeter, the cook,
the busboy.
And it just doesn't
work very well.
I would say Mitchell's
Soul Food just
has one cook and a
very small staff,
if you want to go to Vanderbilt.
That is absolutely fantastic.
But I can't offhand think
of-- what was that guy's name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that Egyptian?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
There's an Egyptian guys
that does everything himself.
And there's only five
seats in the place.
And you go and sit
down, and he makes
you whatever the hell he wants.
Kabob Cafe.
Thank you.
But what's the guy's name?
I can't remember.
AUDIENCE: He does
the decorations, too.
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
He does everything.
[LAUGHTER]
And his brother had a
place down the street
that eventually closed down.
But yeah.
And Kabob Cafe is still there.
So I recommend-- it's
on Steinway in Astoria.
Very, very easy to get to.
You should try that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Brunch seems such an essential
part of the New York lifestyle.
Do you have any favorite
brunch cuisines, or--
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Oh god.
I hate brunch.
[LAUGHTER]
But if it's a good question.
There is a thing
that's "Eater New York"
called Four For the Weekend.
And I always list a brunch
spot there where I've been.
I secretly go to
brunch sometimes.
But there's a whole bunch
of suggestions in there
if you look in "Eater" and
then push the little magnifying
glass and write brunch
in there, and you'll
get just a zillion
decent recommendations.
The reason I hate brunch is
that brunch is like a license
to commit alcoholism.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like most people
that-- and not you.
But most people that
are excited about brunch
are excited for the
mimosas and the alcohol
that they get to drink
after the other alcohol they
drank the night before.
And also, brunch
restaurants, they often
serve a menu where they've
priced up the most boring kind
of plebeian things.
And so I hate-- but thank
you for giving me the chance
to rant about brunch.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You're welcome.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is two fold.
The first one is how did
you become a food critic?
What brought you
into this field?
And secondly, do you have advice
for aspiring amateur foodies?
Because the scene
is so saturated now,
it's hard to be differentiated.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Great.
I love this question.
For the first half
about how I did it,
it was like a complete accident.
This is hard for
anybody to believe.
We live in a bubble
called the Age of Foodism.
And in the Age of Foodism,
everyone is obsessed with food.
And they just like, they're
every meal is important.
They don't go to movies.
They don't go to plays anymore.
They don't go to
dance performances.
They plan, they plot,
where they're going to go.
What is the next place?
It could be either a fancy
place that's been hyped up,
or it could be a secret
place that friends
have told them about.
Anyway, when I started
doing this in the '80s,
nobody wanted to
be a food critic.
It was like, why
would you do that?
Are you crazy?
You just eat what you want
to eat, and who even cares?
So when the Village
Voice came to me
and said, do you want
to be the food critic,
I said, I guess so.
I was working as a secretary
in a real estate company.
[LAUGHTER]
So I said yeah, that sounds
better than being a secretary.
So I said yes, and then
I started doing it,
and I just I had
an avidity for it.
I'd been a washed
out graduate student.
So the idea of doing research
was part of my makeup.
So being a food
critic at that time
involved mainly doing research
and being a social director who
could trick people into coming
to restaurants with you.
This sounds almost
unbelievable now.
But now that everyone
is a food writer--
And for the second
half of your question,
I would say the
most important thing
about becoming a food writer as
a profession is to just begin
doing it now like
you're a professional
and don't look back.
The most important thing about
being a food writer, these days
at least, in the age
when blogs are ascendant,
is to be able to write a lot.
Be accustomed to writing
un-self-consciously.
Practice writing all the time.
Start your own blog.
Start your own Instagram.
And just write all the time.
Think of topics to write about.
For the blog, however,
pick a narrow topic
that hasn't been covered yet.
Whether you write about
Jello in restaurants,
whether you write about
unusual ethnicities
that you've never seen
before, whether you
write about a certain
neighborhood--
pick a neighborhood.
East Flatbush.
Ocean Hill.
Pick a neighborhood
that's not being covered,
and just write
obsessively about it.
If you pick Ocean Hill,
it would be really good.
Because you could go
out there and the food
is still really
cheap, so you're not
going to have to spend a lot
of money to write about it.
But pick some delimited thing
and just write obsessively
about it.
And start sending URLs
around to editors.
Anyone will hire you
to write for free.
[LAUGHTER]
But the trick is
to get paid for it.
And don't quit your day
job, especially your day job
here, until you start publishing
and cash starts flowing in.
Thanks for the question.
AUDIENCE: I know I
could look this up
on a search engine
or something, but is
your brother the food critic
at "The Washington Post,"
or related to you?
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
This is Tom Sietsema,
and I my call him my evil twin.
My mother, who's obsessed
with-- I almost said genetics--
but it's genealogy.
She was obsessed with
genealogy, and she determined
that Tom Sietsema is
my fifth cousin, which
means I'm probably more
closely related to you.
AUDIENCE: I was going to ask
if you could-- this maybe less
relevant now-- but the sort of
big differences between food
trends in DC versus here.
DC also, when you include
northern Virginia,
pretty multiethnic as well.
But I'm sure there's some fairly
sizable gaps between the trends
here.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: There
are giant differences.
To me, DC is not quite
as livable a city.
And I hate driving by
those government buildings
all the time.
It kind of like scares me.
But the food there is
absolutely fantastic.
It's amazing.
They have things that
we don't have here.
They have us completely beaten
when it comes to African food,
and one of the
reasons is that they
have all of these
embassies there where
they have a staff that wants
to eat the kind of specialties
from their home country.
So nearly every nationality
in West Africa at least
is represented by restaurant.
We have a lot of
restaurants here,
but they tend to come
from certain countries.
Not all of them, but I love
going down to DC and eating.
And I love Ben's Chili Bowl.
Who wouldn't?
I wish we had it here.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm from the
suburbs in the Midwest,
and it was a big deal when
we got our first sushi
restaurant in 2005.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT SIETSEMA: What
kind of restaurant?
AUDIENCE: A sushi restaurant.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: And how
far were you from the ocean?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm
from Illinois, so we
were close to Lake Michigan.
Could you talk a
little about what
it takes for foods that start
off more specialized to go
mainstream?
And what kind of foods you
think now are up and coming?
ROBERT SIETSEMA:
That's great question.
And it used to be that you would
be kind of afraid to eat sushi
if you were more than
50 miles from the shore.
But it's Japanese
food is something
that has become
tremendously popularized.
It probably started with
the Japanese miracle, which
was pretty much in
the '70s and '80s,
whereby Japan
finally shrugged off
their inferiority economically
and became a powerhouse.
They've since dropped
from that position.
But the fact that they were
Japanese business people
running all over the country and
representing Japanese companies
meant that they wanted
to have food from home.
And at that time around
Grand Central Station,
we had restaurants
that served fugu,
for God's sake, and
eels, and okonomiyaki,
and things that specialized
in very particular forms
of Japanese food.
A lot of them have
since gone away.
But what it takes is having a
knowledgeable population there
that can cook the food.
I presume that you're
talking about Chicago or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I'm from Chicago.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
Yeah, there were Japanese
people in Chicago that started
making the food, presumably.
And then other people learned
how to make it as well.
But the necessary condition was
to have immigrants from that
country that were there.
And that is usually the
case with ethnic food.
Like I remember when
Mexican food hit Milwaukee.
It was just unbelievable.
This un-reconstructed
Mexican food
from a certain state
in Mexico was suddenly
available along National
Avenue in Milwaukee.
And that's happened
all over the country.
There's been a
revolution whereby
immigrants going
inland-- maybe they
lived originally in New
York or Los Angeles--
and then they started
moving inland.
Particularly true
of African food.
Like Nigerian food appeared
in Chicago maybe 20 years ago,
and was just mind boggling.
There have to be immigrants
to bring the food,
or a mass media that transmits
the ideas of the food.
And now, of course, we
have the-- how is it
that salsa took
over from ketchup
as the national condiment?
That's a story in itself.
But it required
Mexicans to be here
and to bring their salsa to us.
And great chains like
Taco Bell to start
promoting that condiment.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So my questions about
burgers-- the obsession
with burgers in terms of crazier
ingredients and sort of gourmet
spoke burgers that lots of
restaurants in this city
and across the country
seems to be unending.
I wanted to get your
take on that trend,
and your thoughts on sort of how
we got here, where it's going.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Burgers is
an interesting phenomenon,
because burgers had been with us
since the 1820s when they first
started appearing on the
lower west side of Manhattan
to feed German sailors--
without the bun.
And of course, the
bun first appeared
any number of
places-- New Haven,
Connecticut, is one of
the places of claims
to have invented the
hamburger, which had bread.
But eventually
hamburgers had buns.
It's often been known
as comfort food.
But one of the
things that made them
so popular in the
current era is what
I call the glamorization
of plebeian foodstuffs.
And what that means is
that restaurateurs who
would formerly serve
you a steak found,
that by the glamorization
of hamburgers,
they could give you a hamburger
and you would be just as happy.
At one time, a
hamburger was something
that you nibbled at lunch, or
ate at your desk or whatever.
And now suddenly the
attention we pay hamburgers
means that instead of
charging $5 apiece for them,
they can charge $20.
This is not a bad thing.
But that same thing has
happened with pizza, whereby
giant, cheap pizzas shrunk
down to little Neapolitan
pizzas that were suddenly $18.
It's one of the ways that cash
strapped restaurateurs who
occupy this ridiculously
expensive real estate, how
they're able to make
ends meet by fooling us
into thinking that we should
pay a lot more for things
we were accustomed--
AUDIENCE: So you think
it's economics driven?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: It's
economics driven,
but there's no doubt that this
has made every one increase
their hamburger game.
And hamburgers are
1,000 times better
than they were 10
years ago even.
I love hamburgers and I
eat them all the time,
but what has happened to
them is just mind boggling.
They're not the
same thing anymore.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was just curious to see what
your thoughts are on dessert,
and then any good, cheap,
exotic, or different dessert
spots that you know of?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: I was
recently in Chinatown
and ate at this Hong Kong
dessert place where they
specialized in sweet soups.
And it was down kind of at the
start of East Broadway, like 1
East Broadway.
And the name was in
something-- In Dessert.
That was one of the
most interesting.
They had this thing that had
five different kinds of jelly
in it.
And kind of crushed ice.
And that was
really, really good.
I don't really get
to dessert too often,
because I eat so much food.
I would be much bigger than
I am if I ate desserts.
But I love desserts.
There's a revolution
going on in ice cream.
If you like ice cream, you could
go to any number of new ice
cream places in Williamsburg.
Big Gay Icecream is a kind of
redefinition of soft serve,
for example.
Morgensterns-- they've
reinvented the restaurant mix
in.
Do you like ice cream?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Ice
cream is fantastic.
Of course, Chinatown
Ice Cream Factory
was one of the first to
kind of glamorize ice cream
and offer exotic flavors,
likely li chi, and mango,
and things like that.
Almond cookie ice cream.
Things like that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Sorry
my answer wasn't better.
MICHAEL: Cool.
I think we have probably
time for one more.
AUDIENCE: I've had some great
subs in Delaware and New
Jersey.
Do you have any recommendations
for closer to home?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Have you
ever been to Furies House
of Quality?
They make their own mozzarella.
Their in Hoboken.
They're absolutely fantastic.
I would go to Faicco's either
in Brooklyn, in Diker Heights,
or on Bleaker Street.
It has fantastic subs.
You're the vegetarian,
though, right?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: So in
that case I would go--
there's a new
submarines sub spot
that about a block and a half
from Court Street and Atlantic
to the east.
I forget the name of it.
It was the guy that
owned-- Pete Szaz is now
doing a lot of vegetarian.
AUDIENCE: It's like
bomb something?
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Yeah.
Boombox?
AUDIENCE: Boomwich.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Boomwich.
Thank you.
Together, we will pull the names
of these restaurants together.
Yeah, when you have
like 50,000 restaurants
buzzing around in
your head, it's
like, oh, all the
names sound the same.
Yeah, Boomwich has some
interesting vegetarian subs.
AUDIENCE: Thanks a lot.
ROBERT SIETSEMA: Thanks
for the question.
MICHAEL: Cool.
Well, thanks
everybody for coming.
Thanks for the questions.
I know there are books for
sale, heavily discounted books
for sale.
And yeah, please give it up.
[APPLAUSE]